april 7 2021 a trailer is released for a
survival horror game titled abandoned
it's made by an unknown indie developer
called blue box game studios
the trailer depicts creepy flashes of a
forest during winter
voice over indicating a horror survival
story
and a flash indicating this will be
first person
alongside the trailer the playstation
blog releases a post from abandoned game
director hassan carmen
the reaction is not great comments
flooding complaining about the frame
rate
the voice acting and the look of the
hand many feel the announcement trailer
came
too soon before there was anything
substantial to really show of the game
but one reaction to the game caught the
eye of the internet
that reaction comes from jeff keely who
replies to tweet from playstation
announcing the game
keeley responds with the simple gif hmm
very interesting the internet
immediately begins to put pieces
together
jeff keeley has a notably strong
friendship with hideo kojima
creator of metal gear solid death
stranding and
of course police knots
kojima also happened to be behind pt the
silent hills demo that received critical
acclaim before being abruptly cancelled
and recalled from psn
by publisher konami and people started
to draw connections between abandon and
pt
before i move on it's worth pointing out
some of hideo kojima's
history in 2012 metal gear solid 5
the phantom pain was teased in a unique
way by hideo kojima
before it was known that the game would
be titled the phantom pain an
unknown developer called moby dick
studio announced its upcoming game
the phantom pain with the trailer at
jeff keeley's the game awards
the team's website states that the
studio was founded by joakim mogherin
however at the time people on the
internet were quick to realize that
joakim was an anagram for none other
than kojima
then you had the fact that conveniently
holes in the letters perfectly fit metal
gear solid 5 in them
all of this added up and as it turned
out the internet was correct
the phantom pain was secretly a tease
for the newest upcoming metal gear solid
game
next on the docket pt back in 2014
a developer called 7780 studio released
a demo for a game titled pt however
7780 studio was a until then
non-existent studio no hint was given
whatsoever that the playable teaser was
related to kojima or silent hill
until players solved the incredibly
obtuse puzzles
and were able to find a tease upon
completion revealing this was meant to
be silent hills
the game was subsequently cancelled by
konami and pt was pulled from the
playstation store on april 29
2015 back to abandon
on april 8 2021 blue box game studios
post a response on their otherwise
barren website
we have no association with hideo kojima
nor do we claim to have any association
nor was it
our intention to claim such a statement
and
the internet mostly believes them that
was
until their twitter account became
active
first on may 30th they announced an
abandoned real-time trailer ps5 app
that will allow players to experience
all trailers including gameplay reveals
in real time on your ps5
this is due to release june 20th seems
straightforward enough
but then june 15th the floodgates open
blue box tweets that abandon isn't the
real name of their game
and guess the name abandon equals
first letter s last letter l reveal
closing in once again the internet was a
buzz
what game could possibly start with the
letter s and
end with the letter l sonic
spinball
i mean silent hill of course
blue box quickly realizes its mistake
and eventually pinned the following
tweet
we wanted to set things straight we have
no relations with konami
silent hill is owned by konami we do not
have any relations with hideo kojima
it was never our intention to tease the
name of silent hill
we sincerely apologize for this but
it was too late and that was when people
started to notice some strange details
about the
trailer for example isn't it
interesting that in the shot with the
writing on the wall where it says kill
the trespassers
the specific letters that are covered up
by a tree are tp
for toilet paper or looking at it
another way
pt like hideo kojima's pt
or playable teaser which was the silent
hill surprise demo
and hold on a minute the game director's
name is hassan carmen
that means he shares the same initials
as hineo kojima
hk and speaking of names hideo is
japanese for hiro
although notably the kanji of hideo
kojima's name is different than that of
hideo meaning hero
car man's name is turkish for hero
and why is it that if you go to the blue
box game studio's official link youtube
channel
nothing is there except for a banner
featuring hills
and clouds which seems reminiscent of
foggy silent hill
back in august 6 2020 hideo kojima
posted a photo on his instagram with joy
division
that shows a barren of winter forest
which looks almost
exactly like the force that's an
abandoned announcement trailer
and speaking of which reddit users
discovered that the abandoned trailer
was made using a 35
asset set from the unreal engine store
and
hold on a minute of the 12 people blue
box game studios is following on twitter
one of them just happens to be game spot
wait am i do i know something
also jeff keely and those weren't the
only odd correlations
blue box game studios has an incredibly
similar logo to that of playstation
studios
they both feature black or white boxes
within another black or white box
only with the colors inversed and beyond
that
the font used is the exact same minds
across the internet were blown at these
connections being formed
either abandoned was a new alternate
reality game to serve as a breadcrumb
trail to an
upcoming hideo kojima game possibly
silent hill
or blue box game studio was an
unfortunate studio caught up in the
bader meinhof phenomenon
the bader meinhof phenomenon or
frequency illusion
is when after noticing something for the
first time people will start to notice
it more frequently
it's a mix of confirmation bias and
selective attention
and it's essentially what the film the
number 23 is about
i met you when i was 23 and the day we
met was
september 14th 9 14. 14 plus 9 is
23. is it all just a coincidence i don't
know
reddit communities were formed with r
the blue box conspiracy
and after rift our blue box conspiracy
fans were digging up evidence everywhere
steam
playstation store trophies did you see
this thing
i did see that thing but did you see
this thing graveyards oh
hold on no no not not graveyards or was
that where the crucial piece of evidence
we were missing was all along
people started to create fake clues the
internet was quick to find other games
hassan caramen had developed which led
them to the apple app store
of the many apps he had created one of
these was go fit
xl a personal training app hmm
personal training p t
and if this sounds like a stretch that's
because it was
the app store's hassan messaged out that
he wasn't and had nothing to do with the
hassan from blue box
a youtube channel called abandon the
game sprung up but blue box game studios
quickly squashed this rumor on twitter
stating it was a fake youtube channel
that had nothing to do with them
a leaked trailer started to spread this
one featuring incredibly lifelike
graphics
and certainly more than 10 fps
in fact it was almost too lifelike
because it was the fake trailer was made
using footage directly from rambulak
a youtube channel whose creator takes
viewers on peaceful walks around japan
i highly recommend it if you want to put
something relaxing on in the background
and there were many more many of which
throwaway 9669 elite was kind enough to
compile for readers on reddit
whether blue box game studios was
related to hideo kojima or not
they continued to release vague clues on
june 16th they tweeted out what players
could look forward to in their upcoming
game
snowflakes of blood that's an oddly
specific thing to mention
the only thing it seems to relate to is
this 10 second teaser from august 5th
2014. some were convinced that this was
a teaser for the upcoming 2015 game
until dawn
others felt it was silent hill but as
far as i could find
we still never received a full answer to
this mystery
the next cryptic hint came just a day
later june 17th
first we have a q a on twitter with jeff
keely who was asked about blue box game
studios
actually i got uh dm out of the blue
from hassan
um a little while ago asking if i wanted
to sort of help them reveal the game um
over the summer so
stay tuned but i think there will be
more to share uh on this title i'm very
interested i don't honestly know a lot
about it and
we'll all find out together odd blue box
game studios doesn't have any major
games to their name
so again why is jeff keeley taking such
a proactive approach to revealing their
game
this certainly doesn't seem to be just
any ordinary indie game
furthermore blue box game studios
tweeted out company fact
blue doesn't refer to the color it
refers to something else
can you guess it and then on june 18th
the correct answer is
best level user experience it stands for
unique gameplay interactions with
unparalleled user experiences
but how might someone come to properly
guess that for internet users who were
playing into finding every clue possible
about blue box game studios
the answer might have seemed obvious you
see by going to the blue box game
studios website you wouldn't find very
much there today
just a simple post that says we are
preparing for
however by using wayback machine the
internet was able to find that blue box
game studio's website used to contain
a lot more information this included a
massive banner saying
we are blue blue doesn't refer to the
color rather it refers to best level
user experience
it felt almost like blue box was
screaming for people to dig into things
they also used to have a different logo
which didn't so strongly resemble that
of playstation studios
and by using way back machine viewers
could discover
another game blue box game studios had
been working on
rewind voices of the past an emotionally
cinematic drama game
well that doesn't start with an s and n
and an l
but let's talk about rewind for a moment
by looking into it it turns out rewind
was a game kickstarted by blue box
game studios in 2014 the creator is
hassan caramen
matching with that of abandon the game
was described as a cinematic horror game
and looking at the main story chapters
chapter 1 is
abandoned hmm interesting
on april 4 2015 the kickstarter was
cancelled because the team received a
private investor
rewind will be fully funded by a private
investor
this will allow us to achieve our goals
within a short time span
we would like to thank our backers for
their support the campaign shall be
cancelled later today
some speculate that private investor
could be none other than hideo kojima of
kojima productions
however that's all speculation
on top of all of this konami added to
the fire themselves by promoting new
merch to the official konami shop on
june 17th
the image that flashes is clearly a
nurse from the silent hill series
finally the day closes in june 20th
the day of the abandoned app launch
however the app is first delayed to june
22nd and then blue box announces the
trailer app has been delayed for three
days and will instead launch on the 25th
with hideo kojima speculation getting
out of hand on the internet
hassan careman takes to twitter hello
everyone um
this is hassan karma i'm a real person
yeah i'm not
really associated with hideo kojima
not an actor not working on silent hill
and hopefully we'll do a qa
very soon once again speculation quiets
down
many on the internet who compared
abandoned to hideo kojima or silent
hill are inundated with the clown
putting on makeup meme
perhaps the internet was wrong this time
as depresso on twitter points out maybe
the name of the game that starts with an
s
and ends with an l was sonic spinball
all along
or survival that on june 21st
silent hill official reveals that the
merch being tease was for a silent hill
themed skateboard deck
and pre-orders start on june 23rd it
clearly has nothing to do with any of
this
as many on the internet didn't
understand how small indie studio could
garner such attention
blue box game studios points out that
they're outsourcing certain elements
and the game will have a decent budget
they have ceo
leo enen of the studio they're
outsourcing to new our studios
make a video for them recently hassan
asked us to film a short introduction
video about noir to explain
about our role how we are involved into
the project that we are all
real people with names that were working
hard to bring you the best possible
experience
noir is a company of more than 17 game
industry professionals working hard on
different aaa titles as well as great
companies
the part of which you can find on our
website now we need to say that we are
very excited to work with our friends
from blue box studios
on their new game project so here is
that thank you again
later seems pretty cut and dry but
hold on a moment why does the clock
start ticking
yes leo anna made a piece symbol and
snapping gesture with his goodbye
but is there more to it some speculate
that this looks like he's making the
blooper team
logo and hold on
noir studio is only following 10 people
on twitter
blue box game studios is one and another
is none
other than hideo kojima once again a
flurry of new speculations and possible
ruses rushed to the forefront kojima is
pointing at a blue wall
therefore blue box game studios
however june 25th is soon approaching
on june 25th 2021 the day people have
been waiting for
arrives there's no news of an abandoned
app
it seems it was abandoned
finally hassan releases another face
video announcing that
unfortunately the app will be delayed
until august
the same time as the first true trailer
for the game
their twitter banner changes from the
force of their teaser to a dark
and blurry image meanwhile the internet
had discovered hassan caraman's psn
account weeks prior
and after noticing he'd played telling
lies a game created by sam barlow
the same creator of silent hill's
shattered memories later that day
he quickly privates his psn june 30th
konami announces that they'll be
collaborating with bluber team
potentially confirming some speculation
regarding leo enin
that said we still don't know any other
details or if this has any relation to
silent hill
and that's what we know so far
so where does that leave us similar to
before we don't really know
some of the connections to hideo kojima
and pt are truly
odd but they could simply be that and a
furor of the internet fully falling into
the bader mine hop phenomenon
an indie developer who teased vague
hints about their game unaware of the
incredible attention it would cause
and if so receive the tension and
awareness many indie studios would dream
of
but hopefully not at the cost of
harassment or perhaps
it does have something to do with hideo
kojima only time will tell
whatever the case it was a fun rabbit
hole to go down
i want to stress not to harass hasan
bluebox or
anyone else involved no matter what the
outcome may be
if you want to follow along with more
discoveries or potential fake clues
i'd recommend hopping on to r the blue
box conspiracy
and or our blue box conspiracy reddit
user i am not paul paulsen wrote up an
excellent explanation of everything
known so far
including clues that turned out to be
false i'd highly recommend starting
there
and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you